I just think about how annoyed I would
be that people are almost trying to make
you and Kawai like the face of load
management as if you all don't want to
play or you wouldn't play if you could
does it feel annoying to you it's
annoying cuz ultimately we love
basketball you know we love to play We
love to compete that's just how we are
we love to hoop for people to say that
oh they're not going to play we don't
intentionally want to miss games it's
something that we're trying to be
mindful of and be ahead of it's not just
players that's involved in on decision
it's medical staff that have say so in
these situations as well we're mindful
of our bodies if we haven't played or if
we're not suting up there's something
that's going on that's that's keeping us
out of that game